let's talk about tmj relief okay there's
three things that i'm going to teach you
today that can give you a tremendous
amount of relief if you search out
information on tmj you're going to find
dangerous treatments actual surgery
which has major
complications drugs people using splints
that really never do anything and maybe
you went to a chiropractor to get it
adjusted
being in practice for 30 years and
working with the jaw and giving people
adjustments to the jaw i've never once
found that to be successful and simply
because it's not really a bone on a
place that just needs to be put back
into place it's a combination of a lot
of muscle tension you have a little disc
inside the joint right here you have a
lot of things going on however i do want
to say the number one reason
or the root cause of tmj from my
experience
is related to recent dental work you had
some
work done in your teeth and every time
you bite or chew
it throws off the mechanics of your
entire not just your jaw
but the muscles around the jaw
the muscles in your upper neck the
muscles that go down the neck into the
shoulders it can create a cascade of all
sorts of compensations that can really
throw your body off so if you had recent
dental work
go back to the dentist
and have them double check to make sure
that your all your teeth are fitting
perfectly because just one tooth that's
not quite fitting can create
a huge effect on your jaw
now i do want to say one other thing
that i found especially if you have
pain in your right side on the right
side of the jaw right here
suspect potential gallbladder problems
why because the gallbladder being
underneath the right rib cage
is very close to the diaphragm and
there's a nerve in the diaphragm
that if irritated if the gallbladder is
a little bit swollen can activate this
nerve
which goes right up through here to your
neck and the acupressure meridian system
as well can cross over and cause pain in
your right jaw
normally it's going to be in the right
shoulder or the upper back but it can go
right into the right jaw so if you're
working on the jaw for the next 10 years
and the real problem is your gallbladder
you're never going to see change so
whether you have pain clicking
popping let's just dive right into the
three steps okay
the first step is you're going to be
first locating
which
side it hurts the most okay let's say
for example it's the left side right
through and here and it hurts right in
this articulation right here what you
want to do is you want to massage okay
the opposite
side on the muscles okay and you're
going to be basically working around the
joint so if it hurts on this side right
here
don't massage on that side work on the
opposite side and and so you're going to
basically rub right above the tmj joint
right through in here and just going to
massage that really good and then you're
going to work below it because there's
muscles too below that joint and you're
going to just really massage that really
good and even right into the joint as
well which is right in the front of that
your opening on your ear right here so
you're just going to massage this and
what you're going to notice when you're
doing this is going to be very very very
tender like most people haven't realized
how tender it is on the opposite side
where you hurt you start massaging this
area right through and here up into your
skull right through in here
down through here
and it's going to bring relief to this
site so that's number one
um i always recommend that you rate the
severity of pain from a scale from 1 to
10 and then re-rate it after you do this
and then ask yourself uh did the pain
shift okay let's say it went up or went
down
then you massage on the opposite side so
if the pain went down you massage it a
little bit lower
to the tmj on that side okay and it
doesn't have to be any specific type of
massage it can be irregular or whatever
you're just going to activate the
opposite side okay so that's step one
all right step two okay and this is
probably going to give you the most
relief
you have the buccinator muscle and the
masseter muscle okay that comes right
through here
and
you're gonna massage that okay now the
way you're gonna do that
is you're gonna put your fingers or a
finger or thumb in your mouth let me see
if i can show you this a little bit
better when you put a finger up into
your inside of your cheek on this side
what you want to do is you want to come
up a little high okay it's called
superior you want to press up in here
and press outward right through in here
okay then you're going to angle it to
the mid part and press outward right
here
and then you're going to angle it a
little lower and press outward right
here so we're going on the inside of the
mouth and the outside of the teeth okay
behind a few big muscles and we're gonna
gently
press up and out okay and i'll show you
on myself
it's gonna be very tender okay but it's
gonna give you a tremendous amount of
relief
because this muscle is in a constant
state of tightness and spasm so you're
going to give
your muscles a lot of relief you're
going to do both sides so as you just
saw i pressed upward and then outward
and downward and of course you're going
to spend more time holding that position
but don't try to push it because it's
going to be very very tender and you're
going to hold those positions until that
muscle relaxes it's going to release and
your jaw is going to feel really good so
let me do it on the other side with my
finger
so that would be step two okay so we're
working on the
main muscles that cause your jaw to shut
and we're stretching them a bit to
create more space in your jaw
that alone will probably make you feel
really good okay that's step two
and then number three we're going to
exercise the opposing jaw closing
muscles
the great
majority of the strength of your jaw is
in the closing action not opening your
mouth okay and so you spend a lot of
time
clenching or closing so those muscles a
lot of times are over balanced and to
the point where they can create
pain in your in your joints
for this exercise you want to work on
the opposing muscles the muscles that
open your mouth okay
so the way you're going to do this is
you're going to just keep your mouth
shut okay and you're going to hold your
chin and you're going to try to open
your mouth like this and you'll do like
three sets of ten okay now of course if
you do this in public don't mention my
name because it looks kind of funny when
you're doing this but you're just
strengthening the opposing muscles that
have been overworked again giving your
jaw muscle a chance to balance itself
out all right there you have it go ahead
and do this technique right now and
comment down below if it gives you any
relief
and if you haven't seen the video on the
right sided jaw pain that's related to
the gallbladder check it out right here